[Music]
This is the broom house.
People, the
friendly
ones have gathered here. I'll welcome them. They're no ordinary creatures. That's
right. They
're definitely magical creatures of the Bloom or Bison genus. They're their staple food.  It's a
magic power pouring from Masa, a spirit, and a wizard in the atmosphere.In
exchange, it will fly with us, but of course there is a
compatibility between the broom and its user.If you don't like the broom, you won't be able to
ride it.Do your
best to find a partner.
All the girls are cute. How about you?
[Music]
You brought your true self with you.
Oliver: Yeah, you've settled in well. [Music]
With Nanao's magic, it's no wonder.
[Music] That
guy...  That broom is
extremely dangerous. If you approach it carelessly, you'll get seriously injured.
[Music] My
love, the autumn
breeze, was like this at first. I
have no intention of letting anyone but my true master ride it, so I don't have any
intention of forcing myself on someone who refuses.  I'm sorry, but the
little girl here likes this one.
[Music] The
power I received will be with me. I'm lucky to have this
guy as my partner. No matter
how many times I tried, it didn't work, but that's amazing.
He's so
light and
experienced.  Even if you're an average person, it's
confusing to use a broom for the first time, but there's
no doubt that the same
broom that used to fly with my mother chose Nanao
[Music]